David is in Ohio hi David welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show Dave how can I help
so my question is stupidly I've allowed
my see the loans to be on the default
I'm just looking for some advice on how
you would approach getting it back out
of default and begin to come back that
been it out I'm on baby steps he have
already paid off my car I've already got
my thousand dollar emergency fund good
how much do you make in the bank I make
$15 an hour but I work about 60 hours a
week so I'm bringing in about a thousand
a week gonna be here to last just two
I'm trying to get as many hours as I can
yeah you're working your butt off and
country here we cut cut down well done
so how much student loan debt do you
have uh currently is twenty-one thousand
five hundred and ninety five dollars
okay and how long has it been since you
pay payments on it I know that's how
long five years
okay all right see how long has it been
since you talked to him I actually
called him the day after I started was
in there so I called them because I knew
I needed to start working on this debt
thing and I went ahead and paid my car
off that day too and they see they gave
me a couple different options and they
told me they would settle for sixteen
thousand four hundred and ninety four
and I've done my budget and I believe it
would take me about eight months to have
that much money because I really I'm in
a good situation I'm actually learning
from a friend and he actually lets me
live there for free so I'm just bare
minimum I'm just barely paying gas and
electric and water and that's it I'm
willing to throw everything else besides
food at this debt can you know jitsu
mure credits bad yeah okay all right
well you don't have sixteen thousand
today so you can't take that deal what
was the other deal they offered you
I could start paying payments about $80
a month but I have to pay it for nine
months that would come on a default and
then that would after comes out default
it goes back to Sallie Mae and there's
not guarantee that I would be able to do
the the good deal they were going to
give me yeah why don't you tell them
what a column I can tell them you'll do
the sixteen thousand dollar deal you
said you could do it in eight months
yeah okay once your columns
tell them we'll do sixteen thousand rd
or eight payments of two thousand
dollars I kind of mentioned that to him
but they said if I accept the deal I
only have three months to pay them off
yeah well tell them to the tomato plant
that's not the deal you know tell them
you can do two to eight months of two
thousand dollars but I want the money if
not I'll just have to us and I just
can't pay you right now I just start
piling up money